le 26 mars représente une date
douloureuse pour beaucoup de pieds noirs
d'algérie il ya plus de 30 ans en effet
éclaté une fusillade ce jour-là alger
qui allait faire des dizaines de morts
aujourd'hui encore certains essaient de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé et à nice
les membres d'une association du
souvenir organiseront demain une messe à
11 heures en l'église du voeu à nice ils
ont expliqué pourquoi à jean-bernard
vitiello et richard de silvestro
une semaine après les accords d'evian
qui fixe un cessez le feu et les
modalités du scrutin pour une algérie
française ou indépendante le 26 mars
plusieurs milliers de pieds noirs
manifestent dans les rues d'alger pour
soutenir les habitants de bab el oued
dans ce quartier bouclée par l'armée
depuis plusieurs jours soldats français
et pieds noirs se sont déjà affrontées
il ya déjà eu plusieurs morts des deux
côtés ce lundi 26 mars la foule n'est
pas armé pourtant soudain en face d'elle
des soldats tirent
ok
[Musique]
il
visiblement certains soldats ne
maîtrisait pas la situation des dizaines
de morts et de blessés sont comptés
parmi les manifestants beaucoup de pieds
noirs qui étaient sur les lieux du drame
affirme être aujourd'hui encore
traumatisés comme jean-louis délégué de
l'association du souvenir du 26 mars qui
a reçu deux balles dans le corps ce jour
là
ça a été pour nous un choc monstrueux
que de voir l'armée française qui
étaient là pour nous protéger
nous tirer dessus nous tuer à bout
portant nous sans défense et alors que
nous comptions sur elle justement 33 ans
plus tard qu'est ce que vous attendez
d'abord il a connaissance des faits et
la reconnaissance par l'état français
que son armée a tué des français et
ensuite une réparation morale pour tous
les blessés estropiés et noir
l'armée avait reçu auparavant l'ordre de
tirer est-ce que deux jeunes soldats
d'algérie se sont sentis débordée par la
foule et ont cédé à la panique y
avait-il au contraire des provocateurs
infiltrés parmi eux ou dans le quartier
les membres de l'association du 26 mars
ne se font plus d'illusions ils ne
seront jamais vraiment la vérité ils
n'ont qu'une seule certitude distille ce
jour là beaucoup ont compris qu'il
devrait partir du pays où il était né
[Musique]